طيب العلي يوتيوبر عراقيه مواليد 99 اسمها
ترند ومالي الاخبار والمنصات من بعد خبر
مقتلها على يد ابوها في العراق فيما يعرف
بجريمه شرف مع تحفظنا طبعا الكامل على هذا
المصطلح التفاصيل المتداوله بتقول انه طيب
العلي تعرضت للتحرش من سنوات من اخوها
وعلشان كذا تركت العراق وسافرت الى تركيا
وعاشت هناك وتعرفت على شاب سوري اسمه محمد
الشامي ونشات قصه حب وقيل انهم مخطوبين
وبدات على يوتيوب تشارك الناس حياتها
وحبيبها بيشاركها اغلب فيديوهاتها
لو من جديد شلونكم شو اخباركم اعذروني على
شكلي مثل ما قلت لكم بالفيديو اللي راح ما
لحقت اسوي اي شيء
ومحمد
قلبي
هذا اكثر شيء
وخاصه انه
اسم حبيبي
[موسيقى]
المعلومات المتداوله بخصوص الجريمه كثيره
وبعضها حتى متناقض فقيل انه طيبه بعد فتره
في تركيا حنت تحب ترجع وعرضت على اهلها
انه ترجع بس اخوها يترك البيت لكن اهلها
رفضوا ومن فتره طيبه جات على العراق عشان
تحضر خليجي 25 وتعرضت للتهديد المستمر من
اهلها وهي في العراق وبعدها امها ورشت
فيها وبلغت ابوها ورجال العيله بمكان
وجودها عند صاحبتها فراحوا اهلها ورجعوها
على منزلهم في الديوانيه غصبا عنها ولما
وصلوا لبيتهم صار في خلاف بينها وبين
والدها اللي قتلها خنقا روايه ثانيه قالت
انها هربت من ضرب ابوها وحاولت الانتحار
بقطع الشرايينها لكن ابوها وصل لها وخنقها
قبل وروايه ثالثه قالت خنقها وهي نائمه
مين اللي منتشر كمان الساعات الماضيه
تسجيلات الصوتيه صوتيه قيل انها لصيبه
وانها ارسلتها لاحد اصدقائها قبل ما
يقتلها ابوها وكانت بتقول له انه كذا
حيصير فيها هذا غير رسائل مكتوبه كمان في
انها بتطلب منه اذا صار لها شيء ينتبه على
امها ويرجعها البيت ويقول لمحمد اللي هو
حبيبها ما يجي على العراق ويدفنوها وخلاص
المفروض انت
شو مسوي فيها
[موسيقى]
عادي
انت عندك سهله
ابنك راح بعيد عن ابنك بابا
ابوي صدق يحكي يعني الموضوع حيا عنده يعني
شوفوا الموضوع
طيبه
قولي هذا اليوم يا طيبه انا رجعت من الشغل
مفكر بيك وخابرتي قلت لك بابا انا مشتاق
لك وانت اخ
طيوبه يا يوم قلت لي ام علاوي كنت تقول لي
قبل قبل لا يكبر ابنك
هذه التسجيلات والحكايات المتداوله عن
الضحيه عملت الكثير من الجدل وانتشرها
هاشتاج حق طيبه العلي مثل النار في الهشيم
وعراقيين بداوا حتى يتداولوا صور لابوها
واخوها ويصفوهم بالمجرمين وحتى المنظمات
الحقوقيه في العراق كان لها رده فعل على
اللي صار فمنظمه ايسل لحقوق الانسان
والتنميه المستدامه نشرت بوست على صفحتها
قالت في القصه كامله وطالبت باعاده حق
طيبه العلي ووصفت المجتمع بالابوي الذكوري
اللي بينهش فيه النساء وبيفتك فيهم كل
لحظه واما المرصد العراقي لحقوق الانسان
فانتقد عدم وجود مساعي من السلطات لتشريع
قانون مناهضه العنف الاسري اللي لسه بيشكل
خطر على المجتمع بحسب البيان والكل طالب
السلطات التدخل في القضيه وايقاع اشد
العقوبات لكن كثار كمان استغلوا الفرصه
ليعلقوا على مسمى الجريمه اللي هو الشرف
اللي للمره الثانيه بكرر اننا في تفاعلكم
بنتحفظ عليه وانتقدوا القوانين الحاليه
اللي ممكن تخلي مرتكب جريمه مثل هذه زي
والد طيبه ينحكم بالسجن ثلاث سنوات كحد
اقصى اما السلطات فما في منهم اي بيان او
تعليق رسمي للان ولا حتى من الشرطه
المجتمعيه التابعه للداخليه واللي قيل
انها بتعرف عن التهديدات اللي بتتعرض لها
طيبه من عائلتها من ايام طيب معنى من
بغداد مصطفى سعدون مدير المرصد العراقي
لحقوق الانسان اهلا فيك معنا استاذ مصطفى
حضرتك اطلعت على تفاصيل هذه القضيه هل
عرفت اي روايه هي الحقيقيه
شكرا يعني لا توجد حتى الان الروايه هي
الروايه التي نستطيع ان نقول بانها روايه
حقيقيه وموثوقه مئه بالمئه لا احد يعرف
ماذا حدث في منزل
الضحيه طيبه العلي لكن هناك معلومات حصلنا
عليها من
مؤسسه امنيه
كانت هي المسؤوله عن
التحقيق وهي التي تابعت في محافظه
الديوانيه
اجراءات هذه الجريمه
طيبه هي فتاه عمرها 24 سنه هي لديها نشاط
على السوشل ميديا
كانت تعيش في خلال الاشهر الماضيه في
تركيا بسبب خلافات عائليه عادت قبل اسابيع
الى العراق تحديدا عاده الى بغداد سكنت
وفقا لما مكونه في المحضر الرسمي عادت الى
بغداد وحصلت على تطمينات يبدو ان لديها
خلافات مع عائلتها حصلت على تطمينات
بالعوده الى محافظه الديوانيه لكن عندما
عادت يعني تعرضت للتعنيف من قبل والدها
اللي قتلها خنقا وفقا لمحضر دول لدى
السلطات العراقيه المعلومات ايضا تشير الى
ان والدها سلم نفسه الى القوات الامنيه
العراقيه في محافظه الديوانيه هناك ما
ينسب لهذه الضحيه بانها تعرضت الى اعتداء
من قبل
اسرتها ونحن تحدثنا في المرصد العراقي
لحقوق الانسان قبل اشهر عن وجود حالات
تحرش في كل مكان وايضا في المنازل هذه
الفتاه هي ضحيه
لضحيه لما يعرف
داخل العوائل اللي هو مصطلح العيب يجب ان
لا تتحدث عن الانتهاك الذي تعرضت له يجب
ان لا تتحدثين عن التحرش الذي تعرضتي له
على العكس لو انها تحدثت ولو انها لقيت
اذان صاغيه من قبل اهلها من قبل السلطات
لان هناك معلومات من يعني من مقربين منها
من اشخاص يعرفونها قالوا بانها ابلغت
السلطات اكثر من مره عن تعرضها للتحرش
وايضا
يعني تعرضها للتعنيف داخل عائلتها وبانها
هددت بالقتل لكن لا احد يحرك ساكن نعم
هناك مشكله
في العراق وهي مشكله
الشرطه المجتمعيه الشرطه المجتمعيه لا
تتدخل مع كل الاحترام لجهودهم لجهودهم في
بعض الحالات تخشى التدخل في بعض الحالات
الحالات الخطره مثل حاله طيبه يعني
المجتمعيه تابعين للداخليه العراقيه اوكي
نعم نعم الشرطه المجتمعيه هي واجبها
ولديها خط ساخن تتحرك على بعض الحالات لكن
بعض الحالات هي تؤكد انه لا يوجد هناك
انفاذ حقيقي للقانون في العراق تخشى يخشى
عناصر هذه الهيئه الامنيه ان يتدخلوا فيها
لاسباب ربما العائله تغضب منهم ربما
يتعرض عناصر الشرطه الى ما يعرف
القوامه العشائريه او بالفصل العشائري او
يعتبرون بانهم تدخلوا في شؤون عوائل وفي
شرف والى الى اخره فبالتالي هي المشكله
مركبه هذه الفتاه هي ضحيه اعراف وتقاليد
سيئه وانا لا اقول كل الاعراف والتقاليد
سيئه وضحيه عدم وجود قانون لمناهضه العنف
الاسري منذ سنوات تنادي يجب ان نشرع قانون
يناهض العنف الاسري تاتي بعض الاحزاب
المتطرفه وتقول هذا القانون اذا شرع فانه
سيفكك الاسره العراقيه ابدا
سينظم سيدافع عن الضحايا سينظم حياه
الاسره العراقيه اكثر
هي ضحيه مشكله مركبه مشكله مجتمعيه امنيه
تشريعيه في النهايه يعني طيبه واحده من
يعني كثيرات زيها في يعني حوالين العالم
حتى يعني ما هي بس مساله عربيه او عراقيه
بحته فقط على العموم نحن بنشكرك على هذه
المداخله كان معنا من بغداد مصطفى سعدون
مدير المرصد العراقي لحقوق الانسان شكرا
لك
في ختام الفقره المؤلمه هذه حقيقه ما في
كلام قال اكثر تعبيرا من المقطع اللي راح
تشوفوه الان ومتداول على المنصات لقت
متابعين تصريح لطيبه الله يرحمها بتقول
فيها راح يقتلوني راح اموت وركبوا عليها
هذه الاغنيه
[ضحك]
اكرهونا الحب
يكرهون الحياه يكرهون الورد يكرهون النساء
يكرهون النور يكرهون السلام يكرهون الحب
يكرهون الحياه
يكرهون الورد
[موسيقى]